also here tonight a former hawaii
congresswoman and former presidential
candidate tulsi gabbard so tulsi tell me
do you think that parents need to be
concerned about heading to gitmo
every american should be concerned about
what's happening right now ben
this is something that's bigger than
democrats versus republicans what we're
seeing here is about the powerful elite
in this country
using their power to try to silence and
control us
what is so dangerous about this
situation is we have the attorney
general essentially weaponizing our
federal law enforcement agencies
to intimidate and silence the american
people to try to silence us into
compliance essentially
and and the the reality is that as you
know very well whether we disagree or
agree with each other whether our speech
is quiet or obnoxious our our speech is
protected
by the first amendment it's something
that i as a soldier and as a member of
congress took an oath to support and
defend the constitution and i may hate
the speech that you say i may completely
disagree with it but i will lay down my
life to protect your right to say it
one of the things that concerns me so
much about this particular moment tulsi
is that it's not necessarily about the
people who you hear about getting into
fights over this who actually have to go
to court and defend themselves it's
about all the people who stay quiet
because of the forces of the elite
because of big tech because of big
government being potentially used
against them they essentially are
quelled into silence because they don't
want to be at the at the end of that
spear
and that's why it's so important for us
to stand up to speak out to fight back
to take a stand for our freedoms
the kind of action that we're seeing
from attorney general garland it makes
our country look more and more like
we're moving to a police state rather
than being the land of the free and so
now is not the time to allow them to
intimidate us into silence now is the
time that we the american people really
must take this stand for each other for
our civil liberties for our freedoms
because unfortunately those who are in
power those who are supposed to be
leading our country rather than
upholding our civil liberties and
freedoms these kinds of actions are
violating and infringing upon them i
know that you in congress were one of
the major voices pushing back against
the assumption that we should just take
for granted that our nation's
intelligence security and law
enforcement communities that they just
were you know places that we should
trust automatically you wanted to see
them have more oversight more
transparency because you felt that we
needed to be more skeptical that's not
been something that i think traditional
traditionally a lot of republicans
listen to but a lot more of them are
listening to it now what are some of the
steps that we can take to have more
confidence that we won't see a situation
where things like the department of
justice are being turned against our own
law-abiding citizens
well when you hear so easily in this
specific example the counterterrorism
division of our government the national
security branch being invoked to target
everyday americans to target these
parents who because they care so much
for their children are going and
speaking out at these board of education
meetings when you see this happening it
should be a red flag being waived to
every single person about the danger
of these provisions that were passed in
the patriot act after 9 11 to
specifically go after al qaeda the
jihadist terrorists who attacked us on
that day now being redirected
towards our neighbors our friends those
in our community our fellow americans
and so we can only put a stop to this by
continuing to shine a light on it by
holding lawmakers accountable so that
these policy changes uh are made so that
these provisions in the patriot act are
revoked this is what i was working on in
congress and we're seeing now exactly
why it's so important
congresswoman thank you so much for
taking the time to join me tonight thank
you ben hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else